les jeunes enfants sera organisé une
fille qui a six ans comme celle de
nicole courcel et je crois aussi qu'il y
a de bons pères et de mauvais de mauvais
perçues étaient très intéressés dans
dans la fin de a
olivier d'elisabeth badinter part
justement cette apparition d'un groupe
éternelle
cette apparition du père jusque là je
suis appelé le père mère l'avouer
alors qu'est ce que c'est la csn nouveau
la nouvelle famille c'est une belle
famille c'est surtout un nouveau père
qui crée cette nouvelle famille je crois
que depuis à peu près une dizaine
d'années et je ne perds en particulier
il ya un nouveau comportement paternel
vraiment vous dire que le père se
comporte avec son bébé comme une mère il
a ce contact charnel avec la mer ils
sont accusés complètement il le change
il le nourrit le porte sur son ventre
il ya en fait deux contacts corps à
corps du père et de l'enfant qui
n'existait pas il ya 30 ans et
franchement il ya 30 ans j'imagine ou 40
ans si le père s'était promené un père
s'était produit dans la rue avec son
bébé sur le ventre ça va être long on
aurait dit les timbres est venu souvent
et je crois que c'est l'apparition de ce
nouveau père qui donc fait comme une
mère il aime comme une merde on peut se
demander si apprentis façon d'aimer
d'ailleurs et enfin effectivement changé
la famille et je crois que s'il est
apparu ce nouveau père c'est en partie
en grande partie à cause des femmes
parce qu'elles les ont incités à les
aider elles ont incité leurs compagnons
les hommes 15 mai à prendre en charge le
bébé et même si ça ne l'est pas si ça
n'est pas bien selon les normes
psychanalytique actuelle si on trouve
qu'il faudrait toujours gardé la
direction des routes et femmes ont
poussé les hommes à à devenir des pères
effet totalement nouveau nicole
courseulles